[Applause]
this happens whenever you and I are
together first of all since Shirley
congratulations I haven't seen you since
this incredible night and you've been on
the show a bunch of times and this is
insane yeah I mean it's at well-deserved
clean sweep clean sweep at what point
did you realize when you were at the
Oscars that people were starting to hate
you there you know because you it was
what you know it must be weird when
you're just winning everything
absolutely about about four five or six
Awards in we all started looking at each
other the four hobbits all kind of
sitting next to each other in kind of
turns around we're all looking at each
other and this sort of feeling that we
were suddenly becoming the enemy right
you know that Clint Eastwood must be
sitting in his chair right now thinking
those dirty hobbits do you feel lucky
with your large feet so it was this
weird mixture of emotion because we were
so psyched and it was amazing but at the
same time we realized it was quickly
becoming the Lord of the Rings show
right right
well some people is not all that much
fun if one movie kind of does the whole
thing oh sure especially if people are
up against you and they realize at a
certain point I have no chance tonight
this is a steamroller that's coming
through oh my god I understand that you
know Oscar night is known for these
amazingly cool parties where all the
celebrities go and they hang out
afterwards you guys skipped the those
parties and went to a fan party instead
is that right that's right
with who was at this fan party made fans
and obviously but fans and it was the
one ring that fan party they do it every
year for the Oscars in conjunction with
the Oscars and there's like two or three
thousand fans there and and sort of
Hobbit e middle-earth entertainment
what is middle-earth entertainment they
had a roster of bands that did sort of
Celtic music and in fact there was a
sort of Hobbit rap band and I believe
they were in comedy Mills
middle-earth rap and it's all about
Mordor and we've got to get to the you
know and Frodo and the yeah exactly
oh my god do they still say [ __ ] every
now and then I didn't actually hear it
but I'm sure they do
I better be interesting you gotta mix it
up a little